ich grüße herzlich ursula nonnemacher
brandenburgische ministerin für soziales
gesundheit integration und
verbraucherschutz frau nonnemacher noch
regieren sie nicht aber eines haben die
parlamentarier der potenziellen
ampelkoalition trotzdem gestern schon
entschieden die bis zum 25
november beschränkte epidemische lage
von nationaler tragweite soll auslaufen
ist das ein kluges signal in der
aktuellen situation wie wir sie gerade
auch im beitrag gesehen haben
die verlängerung der epidemischen lage
war schon das letzte mal heiß umkämpft
und heiß umstritten wegen der starken
eingriffe in grundrechte der sehr stark
grundrechts intensiven dinge die in §
28a des infektionsschutzgesetzes
geregelt sind wie zum beispiel
ausgangssperren kontakt beschränkungen
da haben wir sicher jetzt eine andere
situation durch die ruhe trat an
impfungen die inzwischen in deutschland
erfreulicherweise erreicht worden sind
aber es ist selbstverständlich kein
anlass jetzt hier von freedom day oder
wir haben alles überstanden zu reden und
deshalb bin ich auch sehr froh dass die
ampel koalitionäre gestern ein papier
vorgelegt haben in dem doch ganz klar
gesagt wird wir schaffen im
infektionsschutzgesetz jetzt wieder eine
gesetzliche grundlage
das masken pflicht abstandsregeln 2g 3g
regeln dass diese dinge auch weiterhin
verlängert werden können sie haben den
freedom day gerade angesprochen also
dieses gefühl jetzt ist die pandemie
vorbei wie wollen sie denn sicherstellen
dass das nicht das signal ist dass von
dieser politischen maßnahmen ausgehen
könnte in die gesellschaft
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass die
fallzahlen in diesem herbst und winter
sogar höher sein könnten als im gleichen
zeitraum für im letzten jahr bin
befürchten sie nicht dass mit dieser
aufhebung der nationalen der der
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite ein falsches signal ausgeht an
die menschen
ich habe ganz klar gesagt wir müssen und
es hat auch die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz immer
wieder fokussiert sagen wir sind mitten
in der vierten welle wir haben gerade in
den letzten tagen sehr starke anstiege
desinfektions geschehens in der
bundesrepublik aber jetzt auch bei uns
in brandenburg wir waren ja bisher immer
noch am unteren level desinfektions
geschehens auch bei uns nimmt das jetzt
wirklich sehr zu wir haben jetzt den
herbst und winter vor uns und es ist
keine zeit für entspannung
es ist bloß halt die frage auf welche
eingriffe man sich jetzt beschränkt und
ich sage unsere umgangs verordnung zum
beispiel in brandenburg beruht auch auf
diesen sachen abstandsregeln masken
pflicht im öpnv beispielsweise
zugangsbeschränkungen hygiene konzepte
und diese dinge müssen natürlich
weiterhin mit großer intensität beworben
und auch verfolgt werden und da schafft
jetzt offensichtlich der bundestag die
gesetzliche grundlage das ist nötig und
das ist zu begrüßen das möchten wir im
übrigen wollte ich natürlich noch sagen
weil ich natürlich noch sagen es bleibt
auch wenn die leute es nicht mehr hören
können natürlich dabei wir haben jetzt
die pandemie der ungeimpften dieser
ausspruch ist und bleibt richtig und ich
kann immer wieder nur dazu motivieren
impfen impfen impfen wir haben immer
noch gerade auch hier bei uns in
ostdeutschland eine impfquote die viel
luft nach oben hat in allen
altersgruppen und natürlich müssen wir
auch die auffrischimpfung jetzt gerade
bei wohlen rahmen und hochaltrigen
weiterhin mit nachdruck in angriff
nehmen also das thema impfen auch wenn
die neuerliche forsa-umfrage jetzt
gezeigt hat dass viele leute halt eben
auch kritisch gegenüberstehen das thema
impfen ist weiterhin ein schlüssel zur
bekämpfung der pandemie wenn sie
noch niedrige impfquote auch vor allen
dingen in ostdeutschland ansprechen bei
ihnen in brandenburg ist die anzahl der
vollständig geimpften im verhältnis zum
bevölkerungsanteil auf dem vorletzten
platz bundesweit sehr liegt bei 60,2
prozent
woran liegt das diese impfskepsis
also ich denke das hat sicher sehr viele
gründe da gibt es nicht einen grund
dafür aber wir haben natürlich in den
letzten wochen und monaten in
zusammenarbeit mit den kommunen wirklich
alles versucht auch durch
niedrigschwellige angebote skeptische
menschen zu erreichen und mit bussen und
aktionen vor einkaufszentren und so die
entsprechend kritische bevölkerung noch
zu motivieren aber wir haben natürlich
hier auch ein verfestigte anzahl an
impfgegnern an sehr kritischen gegnern
und zum teil korreliert das natürlich
auch ganz klar mit der anhängerschaft
von rechtspopulistischen parteien die
entsprechende kampagnen fahren oder auch
stimmung machen gegen impfkampagnen oder
gegen das tragen von masken oder gegen
aufklärungsarbeit an schulen und da
haben wir natürlich große probleme und
dass die impfquoten in ostdeutschland
niedriger sind hat halt auch mit diesem
phänomen zu tun frau nonnemacher wenn
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite auslaufen würde am 25 november
damit geht im bund ja auch ein wichtiges
steuerungselement verloren also ein
stück zentralisierung der korona
maßnahmen die maßnahmen werden dann
wieder in die hände der länder gegeben
dh es kommt wieder eine art
flickenteppich an corona maßnahmen auf
uns zu
in der ich sagte ja gerade dass ich das
gestern vorgestellte eckpunktepapier der
ampel verhandlungs man sozusagen so
verstanden habe das ja gerade eine
bundesgesetzliche regelung für die
maßnahmen die wir weiterhin brauchen
geschaffen werden soll also den
flickenteppich sehe ich nicht sondern es
wird gerade zentral durch den neuen
deutschen bundestag dieses gesetzlich
geregelt werden und damit haben wir
einen einheitlichen rahmen und ich denke
die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die letzte
woche in nordrhein-westfalen getagt hat
hat ja auch entsprechende beschlüsse zur
epidemischen lage gefasst das geht in
dieselbe richtung also ich sehe da jetzt
nicht den flickenteppich sondern ich
sehe dass die instrumente die im moment
von den ländern eingesetzt werden
zugangsbeschränkungen kontakt
nachverfolgung dass das weiterhin
möglich ist durch bundesgesetzliche
regelung das ist dringend erforderlich
aber von daher sehe ich nicht dass wir
da im regen stehen und keine instrumente
mehr ich sagt herzlichen dank für das
gespräch ursula nonnemacher
bitteschön